Hello everybody!
Guys if I sound really fucked up right now, I am actually sick again.
I'll never know what it's like to not be sick!
I feel like I've been stuck in this loop of sickness.
It's like every time I get a little better.
It comes back, it comes back.
Give me a sec, I need to put chat on.
I need to put you guys Back on my screen.
Give me a sec.
I'm a mess right now mentally and physically
Yesterday I was like, I had a headaches and I was like, I don't think I could do a gorilla stream I don't think I could do it.
Oh, that's a little too much now.
Anyway, Johnny Lacon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
I miss streaming.
I miss streaming so much Okay, so um in 20 minutes, I'm gonna disappear to grab my food cuz I didn't eat lunch yet.
Doki sick How could Mint do this?
Burrito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So Cuz like when I was there in America I couldn't tell if I was getting sick like the last two days I couldn't tell if I was getting sick or the air was super dry because like Like the air was was really dry.
Like it was really really dry for so my throat was not happy I also admit get sick.
It's because of me because I was like blowing my nose at her in her room.
So So My bacteria and germs were there and it was like no don't tell me you're sick She was like literally right next to me and I was like, I know I think it's I think I'm just I think it's just a Dry throat.
I think it's just dry throat man.
It's alright But and then like when I got back when I woke up on the day I had to leave I was like Oh, no, it was not just a dry throat like oh, no
Actually sick sick.
Oh no
Anyways, I'm Um, is that good?
Thank you super chat.
Thank you.
Hope you feel better here.
Take this.
Thank you Let's super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Thank you for the 50 gifted ships.
Thank you so much Johnny Lacombe, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you and bite-sized.
Thank you for the aka soup.
Ah, thank you Yeah, welcome back Doki.
We missed you.
Thank you.
Also Ego.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Welcome Yeah, I missed you guys I really wanted this stream while I was like there for work for those who don't know I was gone because like we had to practice for a concert and we had to Try out our 3d models to make sure everything will be okay for next month.
So it was like Non-stop working like we literally didn't stop working since we got there So like we arrived and then like on the first day like I was so okay Okay, maybe like on the first day The first day I could have literally Like done stuff but like on the first day I was so okay I don't know why I was so fucking stupid on the first day.
I was like, all right I'm gonna I'm not gonna sleep so I can sleep on the plane Like that was my mindset cuz like I'm used to like like in I'm used to doing long flights So like I always be like, all right, so if I'm gonna be on the plane, I should not sleep and then and Then like so I can be awake It's I can like stay up and then sleep on the plane.
Well, I forgot what what I fucking forgot Was that the plane ride was less than four hours?
And I did transfers too.
So like I had to do transfers and stuff.
So like I bought Economy tickets for those two plane rides So like I need you guys to know I haven't been on economy for 10 plus years So like I was like, oh, it's like, you know It's a it's two rat plane ticket rides and there's like if there's a transfer in the middle So I was just like can't be that bad as long as I'm super fucking tired Like I'm super tired.
I can fall asleep right away.
Well on my first plane ride the first one The first one, um, not even economy plus it was straight-up economy because I didn't even have to pay for this ticket by the way like I could have I Like I'm saving money and then like I'm remembered I was like wait I'm not even paying for this ticket like the organizers paid for this ticket.
Like why the fuck did I body cut?
Anyway, um Anyway, so like the first one the first ticket right the plane ticket ride I I got the far the like there was no window seat So I got like the far right like, you know the aisle seat because there's three seats So I got the aisle seat and then so but there was a grandma right next to me There was a grandma next to me and um,
I don't think it'll be that bad By the way, I I forgot how little how little space you get So so I was like, I'll make it work But like, you know, I just fucking sleep straight up like I was just like, you know, I'm like considerate about like Oh, you can put your seat in the back up and seat you a little bit.
But no, I'm like considerate I don't want like people sitting behind me to feel uncomfortable and then it costs like a chain of a Comfortableness cuz then they're like, oh this person in front of me is gonna it's gonna like put your seat back I'm gonna push my seat back and then I cost like a chain there anyway So so I was like,
so I I was just like, okay, I'm gonna make this work I'm really fucking tired anyway, because I didn't sleep yet So I was just like like I was like, you know forcing myself to see sleep My neck fucking is not happy about this.
So um This grandma woke me up three fucking times Because she needed to use the bathroom.
I oh, okay.
No JK two times She woke me up two times because she needed to use the bathroom and I was just like, oh my god.
Okay It was already I was not having a great time sleeping on this plane.
The third time was because um Because how uncomfortable the seat was like, you know, cuz I'm sleeping up like like the like there's no slanted when you're sleeping economy and the third time was because it's beverages time and the thing is my my neck was not happy with the position of the seat that I My head was like out of the seat like it was like so like it was not out of the seat But it was like slanted to the out to the aisle and then the the flight attendant fucking pushed
They're pushing the beverage cart, so they pushed my head back to the seat and I woke up and I just see like beverage cart
They're like, you know, they have to push the beverage card They don't like fucking like I hit a run and my fucking neck snaps off because they were serving beverages.
So Yeah, I woke up like three times on the first ride the first one I'm like, oh I should have and I remember what my friends was like No, you should get you should get like first class or something Like, you know, it's like you're not even paying for like the because they pay for the economy ticket So they're like it won't even to be that much because like you already got the economy part paid for so you just put an Upgrade I was like,
yeah, but it's like less than four hours.
Like I don't What's the point?
Like it's less than four.
I'll be fine.
And then my friend was like no You never haven't sat in economy in a long time.
Have you?
I Was like it can't be that bad The thing is some of you guys were like, oh we're like it's economy It's not that bad, but you understand I I had the good life.
Like I I okay I usually I don't get like first class but because it's like a small plane.
They don't have anything beyond they don't have business class they don't have business class because Because it's a small plane because it's like you're only flying to like like a small destination So they only have like one class so I was like so but I never like actually I've only flown first class once in my Life,
so like usually I just get business class Like if I want like an actual good time and I do like like 10 plus out I usually do 10 plus I I've always done 10 plus hour flights I haven't done like a super short flight in like long time.
Um, I never I think I rarely ever fly to like I've rarely ever fly to like America so like so like I was like Oh my god, like like how bad can it be like?
But like I know what it's like to be in business class.
So I was like, oh, you can't be that bad like
Economy plus or like business class so I was like can't be that bad.
So so I it was really bad Like I I was so tired.
I was so fucking I was so fucking tired on the plane cuz I didn't sleep I didn't sleep and then Then a grandma kept waking me up and then a flight attendant woke me up because my head was in the fucking way of the aisle and then so I was just like oh I was like no,
I I knew the good life It's like it's like when you when you play on 60, okay So for the gamers out there who don't go outside It's like you used to play on 60 frames You used to play on 60 frames or 60 Hertz monitor and then you upgrade Do a hundred two hundred and forty four Hertz monitor for the first time like you can't go back like It's just like that.
You literally you literally can't go back.
It's so it's like the gap between economy and economy plus like even I would fly economy plus Then a gap between economy and economy plus it's way too much for me And like and then our economy and business class It's just I've seen the light and then like I'm like,
I can't I have to keep making money So like I don't have to go back to those times
Thank you save from being eager you decide he's a guide from my a beverage cart crazy Thank you for the aka soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
I'm a kid.
They use super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you I'm don't he just want to say how proud I'm of both of you for putting so much work into this Can't wait to see you both on stage.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Yeah, I was thinking a little super chat.
Welcome back to a game So you celebrate my birthday stream to rock say it's your birthday.
Thank you super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear guys Happy birthday to you.
Yeah Alright, give me a sec.
I'm gonna check my uber eats cuz I didn't have lunch yet and it's dinnertime I was so tired.
I literally okay.
It's in 10 minutes.
Okay, it's a 10 less than 10 minutes I literally like I just slept the entire day.
I was so fucking I uploaded a waiting room and then went back to sleep So I'm so done I was like, you know, you're sick and you're just fatigued all all the time.
That's me right now.
Um But yeah, so that was the first flight the second flight was okay because like I got to actually I got the window seat that time but it was like it was not like a long it was like an Hour flight so like I still got the window seat.
So I was happy It's so economy by the way on the flight back I got like economy plus which was a lot better like I was actually happy Well, not that happy because on economy plus on the flight back I was the middle seat and like I was the middle seat.
I couldn't Okay, JK.
No, I remember why I was mad.
I was so mad.
I May as well just be like terrible too because like even though I have more leg room and like my chair is at least finally slanted I couldn't I I Didn't realize an economy your seats are not slanted.
Like how do you live like this?
Why is the chair not slanted like I Didn't understand so like anyway, anyway economy the chairs are slanted and it was like a harsh reality for me So like anyway, they call me plus the chairs are slanted.
So Yes, our seats are slanted a little and our seats are it's actually crazy our seats are slanted in business class and economy plus but
It's a little slanted in economy plus in plus and up It is I swear cuz like I literally didn't call me plus and I was like wow the cheers are not straight this time
I was like, wow, these chairs aren't straight up
Anyway Slanted is premium.
Yeah, like got pay extra for like default slanted seats like Anyway Anyway, so I was like the milsy was fucking terrible, you know why it was even worse because the lady in the the lady in the window seat is like She was like it was her first time flying.
I could tell you know, I know why I could tell it was her first time flying because She left the fucking window open and like the Sun was shining through our side of the plane Like like I was sitting on we were sitting on the left side and the Sun was shining on the left side and I was like she was like one of the only person in our row that kept her window open and She was taking photos of the sky
But it wasn't like a one-time thing she was taking multiple photos of the sky Throughout the plane ride and in my head.
I was like Fuck is it's the sky Changes like when you ride the plane for the first time like it's like if you've done multiple plane rides, it's the same sky
Multiple throughout the plane ride and I was like what's changing nothing is changing outside
I Couldn't because the Sun was shining through and I was trying to watch my show And like the thing is because the Sun is shining through My screen was like getting hit by the Sun.
So like So like I wasn't I was like, how do I pass the time?
I have to like put the phone I couldn't put the phone on the table.
That's the thing the glare Yes It was the Sun glare like I couldn't put my phone on the table because the Sun was fucking shining through and my arms were tired I was like, I don't wanna bring the phone up to me.
I was like there's a table for a reason I just wanted to watch Kung Fu Panda 4 I'm sorry.
There was nothing else to watch like I was like the only that was like free entertainment Cuz like you get to it's like go to a website and like yes, I watch like 20% of come Oh my god, it's so bad.
Um, like but like I already I'm already going through it So like this I can't feel worse than I already do so like Oh So Or is this no, it's for right?
Yeah, they're at number four now, so it's really bad I watch 20% of it and then like I'm never finishing that movie like don't that watch Kung Fu Panda 4 I started watching Kung Fu Panda 4 Heading it heading to the place and then like I still haven't finished it when I mean Continued it on the plane right back But I haven't finished it because like I always do on the one-hour flights,
but even then I would stop Cuz I couldn't finish it.
I would just stop at a certain time because I was like, this is such a bad movie But I need something past the time While I was there, um Anyway, so like that's why I was like really fucking annoyed by this lady next to me because I was like why?
Why do you still need to take pictures of the sky it's been the same fucking like nothing has changed Like I would understand if it was like, you know the fruit like a couple pictures fly taking off and then you know a couple pic like a picture like when we're about to land like I Understand that but she was taking it like every I swear every 30 minutes.
She was saying pictures of the sky I was like and I was looking at the sky It's the same sky like nothing changed like if you're not gonna be sending these photos to anybody you never know looking back at these photos like
I just wish she closed the window.
I was not happy with that Okay, let me see when my food's gonna get here.
Sorry guys.
I didn't have I didn't have oh, it's almost alright I'll be right back everybody Always oh he's here here.
Let me send um, okay I'll be right back guys.
I need a grab.
I didn't need lunch.
I'm sorry.
Um, I'm We I'm heading it Heading downstairs now.
Sorry.
I'll be right back.
I need to grab food Okay, let me make my text Okay grabbing food, please Please wait BRB.
All right There you go Grabbing food, please.
Wait, I'll be right back everybody.
I'll be right back
Back on back home so happy Let me put this where was my story time First who's rewarding what I'm eating it's like this It's Chinese food.
But like this restaurant has been like there for like 10 plus years now so it's Even longer than that.
So it's like a childhood restaurant of mine and like I'm super happy because like I can't believe it's still like there I Order it because like, you know It's so good and it's like it's been here for so long They're still open.
Yeah, it's like it's just like rice and with my poor tofu and My poor tofu and like with beef and stuff and Cabbages, so it's like oh, it's it's really good and I also got I bought this like chili sauce made by a made by a Japanese grandma.
So like I have this like jar of chili sauce that's made by a Japanese grandma and it's so good It's oh my god.
It's really really good.
So I'm like super excited Also, check on Chicago.
Thank you for the super chatting.
Thank you.
It's my birthday weekend and wanted to throw down Some birthday funds for your way.
Don't you so welcome back.
Hope you have a great week Can get a quick happy birthday, of course.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Jakarta.
Happy birthday to you Yay
So yeah, sorry I'm eating in this stream I didn't like I said, um, I was so tired today that I I like woke up and then made my waiting room and then just slept just kept sleeping I got back from my flight and I had a headache and then I was like, oh my god.
I was so fucking Yeah, I was so out of it.
Yes I couldn't stream at all.
Um, I Also got like, um What is it called?
as I got like chicken as well like fried chicken, but like the way the Chinese style fried chicken so it's like a little it's like saltier You might know what you know, I know what I don't know what how to say in Chinese like the name of it But it's like it's like those like the salty fried chicken.
Um So, yeah anyway Burrito, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is there Chinese?
Would you recommend that most people in the West might not try it?
I like Chinese things.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
Um, I would oh, there's so many I think okay to be fair.
I have like particular said uh Chinese food I like What is it so good and one of my favorite is I think I talked about this before and it's like I like a lot of Hong Kong style Chinese food because I I also grew up on it and But like So my favorite top favorite,
this is not Hong Kong style Chinese food it is a Hauser guy Which is like if you direct translate it, it's like mouth-watering Like it's like mouth-watering chicken or like what if you direct direct translate it it is It's saliva chicken but how so guy but only if you like spicy food,
I really like Chinese spicy food so mouth-watering chicken is like basically like cold chicken drenched in chili sauce like it's It's really It's just that it's like Cold chicken and it's all it's just trenchant Chili's chili oil It's just like yes, saliva chicken.
It's just drenched in chili oil and and It's so good though.
It's really really good And then my other favorite is a total C which is like it's basically a diced potato diced potato diced potato drenched in vinegar and and Spices and it's so good.
Oh and I have it for rice.
I have it.
I always order If I could this is my go-to order.
It's those two with rice and that's it Really if I could just eat those two with rice, I'm good to go like I'm actually like I'm happy
It's so good, I think it's vinegar right it's total see you with vinegar because I know it's like a little a little sour I think it is.
I don't remember fully like the ingredients to make it but it's so good and then like my favorite fried rice I'd rarely ever eat fried rice because I just have white rice, but my favorite My favorite fried.
This is like a little bougie though Cuz it's like my grandpa would order this for me like I remember when I had it with my grandpa cuz he's like so fucking bougie He's like so fucking bougie So like I remember when I was like in China for the first time like not the first time but like when I When I was in China when it when I was like I think like 10 or something and then my grandpa we were at a little like really fancy Chinese restaurant and Yeah,
the grandpa that does golf.
Yeah.
No.
No, he's like bougie as fuck like he's like
Anyway so so like I remembered because like He ordered this special fried rice for me because I was very picky with food and I was like I was like, I didn't know.
Okay, so like I was really picky with food because like, um, You know, like I I lived in Canada.
I lived in Canada for the first like 10 years of my life and that to move to Asia and then so I was like I didn't know what to eat cuz I was like not used to this like I Was so not used to it So I was like super picky with food cuz I was like, I don't know like all my favorite food I can't even eat anyway I was like,
I don't I don't know what to eat cuz all my favorite food you guys don't have Cuz I grew up in Canada Oh
No, I was like you really I'm not picky and I'm not like that picky I'm not picky anymore because I ate like so many different types of food I'm growing up, but you know, I was really young I was I was 10 and I was really young and like, you know Young kids are like known to be super picky with food.
So I was like I don't know what to eat and I remember what the okay.
It's like The fried rice in particular, okay, wait, let me see I could find it fried rice I try to remember exactly what it's called.
It's like with egg whites and and like the
Billionaire fried rice with egg whites and shredded compoid
Cuz it's like dried scallop
Billionaire fried rice with egg whites and shredded compoid This legendary fried rice is believed to named after and created by a Hong Kong Billionaire who instructed his chef to prepare healthier fried rice on the advice of his doctor.
Oh
Yeah, no, it's so good it's so good like it's actually like it's um, it's like um It's like egg whites with dried scallop and it's honestly one of my it's what is my favorite It's my Favorite fried rice order ever like I don't think I've ever had fried rice as good as this like as good as this combination
Um It's just yeah, but it's oh it's it's have really healthy and it's like oh, so I'm gonna put my I'm gonna put my chili My special chili sauce you saying a bill apparently a billionaire fucking came up with this.
Apparently.
I didn't know that I'm gonna know that But it's like you you won't see in a regular and they're like, you won't see it in a regular Um like in like a more You'll find a traditional Chinese restaurant You won't find it in like like I don't know like you won't find this fried rice in the more like Western gear Chinese Restaurant you find it in a more like traditional like,
you know If you see Chinese people eating there, you'll find this fried rice because they don't normally make them how would I know because I keep trying I would I sometimes I'm gonna chase that high that China like the The That specific fried rice.
I would really really want it But like it's so hard to find sometimes like in here like it like cuz like it's like in particular In the particular yet to find it in a particular Chinese restaurant.
It's like really difficult So, oh my gosh whenever I remember I like whenever I can order it I would order it because I just I love I love I love it so much especially with like Especially if it's like cuz it's like dried scallops so dry scallop is like really like a particular ingredient,
too So it's not like a usual ingredient that you would have
It's not hard it is I don't know it's just like you don't normally Find that particular ingredient in restaurants Lord Kuro says they give us super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you adding to the list of birthdays Today, can we get a happy birthday for accidentally on Rachel and Andrew?
Of course?
Thank you, happy birthday to all of you happy birthday to all of you Have a birthday dear Lord Kuro says actually and Rachel and Andrew.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah So yeah, it's like that's why it's like particularly difficult to find um I'm trying like I mean I could talk about dim sum.
I talked about like my favorite dim sum already so in the past So like these are like my favorite Chinese food in general and I love tomato with with scrambled egg Oh tomato is scrambled egg is so good because it's like it's like a little sweeter so tomato But scrambled egg is like just a little bit Sweeter and stuff because they make it like they add like a little sweetness to it and it's so good And then you you pair it with rice in it.
Oh my god.
Oh Sorry, I'm making you guys hungry.
I'm sad.
Thank you for the Akasupa, thank you.
Thank you.
Teach me cooking.
Don't you think you're the Akasupa?
I need to get cooking utensils first I still don't have to cooking stuff in my apartment
Hmm I Can I can't cook I just don't have any cooking utensils so I haven't cooked in a long time.
I Can't cook.
I just haven't cooked in a while my favorite meals to make cuz this is wasn't taught to me by my mom um So I learned how to cook it is she didn't teach me I googled it She never taught me how to make it so I Love I loved it so much cuz when I was growing up I ate this when I was growing up So I googled how to make it and I learned how to make it from Google Is honey?
It's not a honey honey chicken wings with a buttered salmon, those are my they're like my raised by Google They're my favorite meals to cook with rice paired with rice because it's so good Buttered salmon and honey chicken wings.
Oh my god, and I learned how to make those up from Google
It's so so good Johnny, thank you for the magenta soup Thank you.
Thank you.
Now that I think about it.
My parents will always ship me home a bag of dried scallop They're always the big ones that are super pricey, too.
Here's a dried scallop Or just spend it on bougie rice.
I guess They could thank you No, no, they give us super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you cookie No pressure.
I would actually buy cooking stuff I think next week when I cuz like I do have I'm gonna like make sure my schedule is a little freer next week So I can actually buy cooking equipment.
So like next week is today is the week.
I'm finally gonna have cooking In your magenta soup, ah, thank you.
Thank you and some plates finally in some place to a set They give me a chance to soup buddy.
Thank you Some of that learning to adult as a realization that following a recipe is sometimes results in a better result than the past Recipe they give them a gentle soup, but they can thank you I'm finally integrating into society guys.
Okay.
So anyway, um, oh made it Andrew says Zephyr can't get one Birthdays, I don't feel left out.
Thank you His name is now Andrew now Zephyr if you're here change your username to Andrew Zephyr, so I
Name is now Andrew Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Andrew Zephyr Happy birthday to you.
Yeah now you have to change your name to Andrew Zephyr now
Anyway, um, okay, where was I where was I my story before I left for food?
You keep my new my birthday gift to you is that you you're now I shall rename you You heard First you let him die as a dragoon all those years ago.
Now you force him to be an Andrew
Johnny thank you.
I better I use chat GPT for pressure pot.
You can just Google
Any different Thing it was super chat mobile.
Thank you.
Just make it harder for you.
So what the fuck?
Anyway, where was I story?
Oh, yeah, so I didn't sleep much heading there So I was really fucking tired.
Obviously, I was like super fucking tired and I remembered oh shit The streamer Awards nominations are coming out today that day like That day so I was like, oh my god, like oh my god like the nomination So and it was coming out at like 12 p.m.
So I was like, oh I should so like I was like Oh, I should I said I should like Pull it.
I should pull it up on my on my phone to watch it because I was supposed to start at 12 p.m I was really fucking tired, by the way So like, you know, I was being driven to the hotel Well saying and I was like, I was like, oh my god.
Oh my god.
It's gonna be out and then fucking okay So like no like it's like it's it's like the real sucks But apparently, um, I waited two hours before I waited like an hour two hours Before like they said anything but like wasn't even two hours two hours.
Okay, so the stream started in an hour started an hour late because apparently um Before the stream is supposed to start Okay, I'll put the link up after the story I should I should put the link up during the story like So what happened was that basically Basically Their OBS deleted all their scenes just before they were about to start So they had to redo all their scenes for the stream,
but that means I had to wait I was like hold, hold.
Okay, I got nominated
For best vtuber of the year I would love to have your vote Okay Anyway, so basically what happened was that their OBS crashed before they were about to start the stream So they remake everything and it was so scuffed I was like watching it and then they kept pushing that that intermission to remake everything Like every time they had to keep remaking the stuff for everything.
So they had like intermissions and stuff No I was already really fucking tired.
I couldn't sleep like I could have slept.
I couldn't sleep on the on the Car ride because I kept thinking I Really want to see what I was curious I was like, oh my god Am I gonna get nominated this year because I was like, um, I saw like a lot of people nominated me So I was like, oh maybe this year I have a chance like,
you know So I was like, I was so nervous and everything.
So I was just sure I wanted to watch it live But there's so many technical difficulties, but I was so anxious that I like stayed up for three hours for the Vtuber category The thing is, um, I was in the hotel room still watching It's not even a Vtuber stream,
it was a fleshy, it's a fleshy stream.
It was from CutieCinderella So like I was like just waiting for three plus hours waiting for the Vtuber category Because I didn't realize that the Vtuber category I thought the Vtuber category was an early thing But like because I didn't know what the order was of the nominations So I thought the Vtuber category was early,
but it was all the way near the end.
It was near the end
I had to wait So I had to wait for like, um So like because I didn't know when it was up So I just kept watching it and I was even I made it to the hotel room and I was still Waiting up for the nomination.
So I was just lying in bed.
Just watching the stream being like, oh my god Oh my god, it was like and in my head.
I was like, what if i'm not even nominated?
I wasted time
I was like, I was like at that point at the third hour mark.
I was like, oh my god What if I wasn't even nominated?
I could have slapped You But I was I was nominated for best vtuber of the year I was I was so I like even I was actually I was so surprised I was like I was screaming in my hotel room.
I was screaming in my hotel room.
I was like, oh my god And I was like, I was so happy.
I was like, thank you guys so much for nominating it.
It's It's crazy.
I was gonna make a more formal tweet about it I was also really fucking tired I was like i'll make the formal tweet when I get back because i'm waiting for Um, then they sent me an updated graphic Of the streamer awards because they sent me one with retro doki They sent me a picture of retro doki and i'm waiting for correct.
I submitted the new visuals for it yesterday.
So I mean, this is what they sent me and I was like, oh this is I was like, um, can I have one with my new visuals and they're like, did you resubmit it?
I was like Yeah, and they're like, okay, we'll send it to you whenever we fix it.
I was like, okay But this is they sent me this I was like, I can I have Where did you first off where did you get this picture?
I was like, where did you get this picture?
So so they sent me this and I think that was also like what they put up there too so um, so I was like, I need an updated visual like the use yeah, it's like they used my high school photo like
Um Um, anyway, so they got sent me this and I asked for a newer one with the newer Yeah, I look like I look like i'm so head empty right now.
Um, but yeah no, I was fucking I was I I it was really surreal to see especially with All those like all the other amazing vtubers up there I think I was like am I the first youtube vtuber to be nominated?
I don't know.
Am I?
I don't know if i'm the first one in the streamy awards.
I know i'm not the first one in the vtuber awards well, I wasn't even nominated for vtuber awards last year for best vtuber of the year, but like um Am I the first youtube vtuber to be nominated in the streamy awards?
Oh, yeah
I don't even go on because like a lot of people Criticized in the past the streamy awards being like it's very twitch twitch centric, but jokes on you I don't even I don't even show up on twitch when i'm forced to When I have um speaking of forced to I need a stream rest,
I don't know if i'm streaming it tonight Am I just streaming it tonight or and tomorrow or like we'll see We'll see how I feel today because like shout out to sykkuno for like doing the twitch drop stuff.
I'm, so sorry I could not stream rest at the Um at the hotel because for some fucking reason I couldn't get the high speed internet option like also I was really fucking tired I was really I was really Uh fucking tired, so there was that too But the fact that like like mints kept had the option to have high speed internet But I couldn't every time I try to do it in my room.
They're like, sorry This option is not available for you.
And I was like, what do you mean?
It's not available to me Like I use the same information menus and then like the organizers like Like asked about at the front desk being like yeah Whatever when people in this room can't get the high speed internet.
They're like, oh we fixed it, but it wasn't fixed So I was like i'm cooking.
Oh, I don't want to get while do I stream?
I was just like how the fuck do I stream also like speaking out.
Okay, this is like unrelated but um um When I was like leaving canada Um when I was leaving canada to america, you know Like the immigration there was like the immigration stuff like in the canadian part of the airport and they're like, what do you do?
And I was like I do I do youtube and then he like like he just like The moment I said youtube he just handed me my passport and was like you can go now I was like, is he like judging me like in my head.
I'm just like are you judging me?
He's just like i'm done talking to you
He just like he instantly gave me back my passport and was just like, all right
Anyway, so I was freaking out because like obviously for the the streaming awards it's like more towards twitch streamers, um a lot more geared towards twitch streamers because like um That's where a lot of like the streaming especially in like the west na That's a lot of words like na streamers are on the platform And I was so I I didn't think I'd get nominated and I had like a small hope and that's why I stayed up to watch the nominations being out because I was like what if I am nominated but like what if I want to be watch it live if I was so it was It was so surreal because like there were so many amazing,
you know, amazing content creators that were nominated and see voting matters guys The voting matters for youtubers guys And I was just like Um, I was like I was so surprised.
I I know that I had a small hope but I was also I was so surprised too because I was like, oh my oh my god, like It's so it's because like i've been through a lot.
We you guys been through a lot.
I've been through a lot In a year, it's not even been a full year yet.
Like since since we came back in february so It's really crazy to see myself being up there As vtuber of the year when I didn't even come back in january.
I came back in february And the year isn't even over The year isn't even over and like i'm up there with so many like amazing streamers in all the categories Nice, we got nominated too.
Nice.
We got nominated as as um One of the best uh battle royale streamer Um, so he's up there too.
Like a lot of my friends as well are out there And and it's like it's just super surreal to see And just like so like thank you dragons for nominating me because it's like 70 percent fan voted and 30 percent.
Uh judged by a panel And so thank you guys for the popularity contest vote because like, you know Back in high school and middle school.
I didn't win the popularity contest for like student council So There was always one person that was more popular than me and even though I was smarter um for some of those positions it didn't matter because it was fucking high school and it was all about popular vote like I did I was a student council treasurer but like what I I got a student council treasurer So I was running up against a teacher and a secretary,
but could never get president because I was just not popular enough for president.
I remember one time I tried to run for student council president, and then the person I was running up against... I told this story before.
The person I was running up against was the daughter of the principal.
So like, and she didn't even put any posters out.
She didn't put any posters out.
She was like, in her speech, she was like, you might notice that I don't have any posters or like marketing for my student council presidency campaign.
It's because I'm thinking about the environment, and I'm here, and my platform is that I'm trying to be more environmentally friendly for the student body.
So that's why you didn't see any campaigns about me posted up.
And I'm like, that is so fucking bullshit.
You are lazy.
I was like, in my head, I was like, that's so fucking, I know you're, you were just fucking lazy.
It's not even that much paper.
Anyway, she became the president of the student council.
So yeah, anyway, so thank you guys for nominating me.
Anyway, because of this, I didn't sleep that much.
But apparently not, because she became president.
She won the popular vote, apparently not.
Not everybody knew, but she won the popular vote still.
I'm still, it's been a long time.
It's been like a long time since high school, and I'm still fucking, I'll still remember her name too.
Maddie.
I'll remember you.
I'll, I forgot so many other people's names, but I'll remember your name.
I don't even remember if that's actually, yeah.
Maddie.
Despite, it's been, it's been countless years, and I don't remember like 80% of the people in my class name at that time.
But I'll remember her name.
I'll remember her name.
I actually don't, I'm like trying, okay, I'm like thinking, do I remember some of the, some of my classmates back then at that year?
And I was like, no, there's a lot I don't remember.
There's actually a lot of names I don't remember.
What a grudge.
It was the most bullshit thing.
When I heard that speech, I was like, you gotta be fucking kidding me.
When I heard that speech, I was like, you gotta be fucking bullshitting me.
That is so fucking, oh my, that is so bullshit.
I was like, no, there's no way.
You, you did not fucking, that was not your intention.
You were lazy.
I know you were lazy.
That's why I remember, it's so, like, I'm holding this grudge to this day.
Thank you, thank you.
She out-politicianed me.
Yeah, she fucking did.
Like, that's impressive.
I was like, you're already the principal's daughter.
Like, do you really have to, oh my god.
Like, it just, like, rubbed in my face that, like, she's the principal's daughter, so, like, now she can just win.
I'm doing nothing.
I wouldn't, if she did something, if she campaigned a little bit, I wouldn't have been so fucking salty.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't have been, like, so fucking, oh.
If she campaigned even a little bit.
But no, no, she did nothing.
She just went in there being like, I'm the daughter of the principal.
And then she had to lie to my face, being like, I'm just trying to be environmentally conscious about the, that's why I don't want to put any campaign posters out.
Or, like, campaign at all.
Like, anyway.
Code, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I love how consistently you remember stuff that spikes you specifically.
That's why, oh shit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
SageN, thank you for the super chat.
Anyway.
Back to my original story.
Sorry, I got a little sidetracked there.
By that girl from a long time ago.
So, obviously, when, you know, I finally, by the way, I just watched it in my category.
And then I closed the stream because it was over.
Because I was like, I got what I fucking wanted finally.
And then I took a nap.
And then I passed out.
And then, so, like, obviously, a lot of time was wasted.
Because I was just so fucking tired.
So, I could have, like, we could have done other stuff.
We could have, like, you know, signed the postcards on the first day.
And, by the way, we didn't get our postcards until day 2.
Because we forgot to, the organizers forgot to give it to us on day 1.
Because we were also, like, super tired.
Like, we were tired from the flight over.
But, yeah, we got the postcards on day 2.
And that's why we were signing.
Because we had signed 200 postcards.
And on day 2, we were given one marker.
Because we were given a pack of markers.
And we were testing out which marker would look the best on the postcard.
And the color we ended up choosing, there was only one of it.
But it was already too late to ask for another one.
Because it was already late at night.
And we're like, well, obviously, we gotta get it on day 2.
So, Min and I, we had to share the marker between us.
So, she would, like, start writing.
And then when she was done, it was my turn.
Like, obviously, that was not very productive.
It was not very productive.
And we were already very tired from dance practice and stuff.
Because in the dance practice, we were also in the 3D stuff, too.
Because we wanted to practice in 3D.
Because dancing without the 3D suits versus in the 3D suits is so different.
And, like, when we were practicing our dances and stuff, we had to change some of the moves.
Because we kept, like, tangling it up on the wires and stuff.
And so, we had to, like...
We were, like, swapping...
We had to practice in the suits and stuff.
So, like, we wouldn't...
Like, we would get used to it and everything.
And then we also, like, didn't...
We had to do the dances where we were both together practicing.
Because now that, you know, we're together, we have to, like, you know, make sure that we were doing the spacing correctly.
And, like, the spacing and the...
And, like, you know, making sure, like, we have, like, interactions and stuff in our dances.
So, we had to make sure everything would be okay.
So, we were doing that.
It was... Oh, my God.
We were at the...
We were practicing for so long.
We were...
It was so tiring.
But, anyway.
So, day one of being there.
I was so... We were... We...
I was so tired that I, like, took a nap right after the VTuber nom...
The VTuber category nomination.
And when I woke up, it was already dinner time.
Well, obviously, they were waiting for me for dinner.
I felt so bad.
I felt so bad because they were waiting for me for dinner.
Because they were like, Hey, Doki, are you awake?
I was like, I'm sorry.
I passed out.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
Mint got free shoes.
I should have asked for free shoes.
Because, like, we're supposed to have, like, non-reflective sneakers.
And she didn't know.
Because, usually, we're provided the sneakers and stuff.
But this one, we...
She didn't bring any because she thought she was...
They were like, oh, we'll buy you sneakers.
And then I was like, oh, I don't need it.
I already brought my own shoes.
Because I was like, oh, they already spent so much money on us.
And then... So, then when we got to the studio...
My shoes were apparently reflective.
I didn't know.
I couldn't tell.
I couldn't tell they reflected.
I was like, wait, these are reflected?
And then...
Because, silly me, the Nike logo is reflective.
Like...
I didn't realize the...
I didn't realize that the Nike logo was, like, reflective.
Because, you know, it's the logo.
So, I was like, oops.
So...
And then they were like, oh, don't worry, we'll just tape up the logo.
And we'll just tape it up.
And I was like, I could've got free shoes.
I'm just thinking, like, oh my gosh, I should've also been, like, free stuff.
Let's go.
I'm so stupid.
Why did I...
Why did I, for one time in my life, decide to have a conscience?
I should've been greedy.
See, guys?
Doing a good thing is not the right thing.
That's the lesson I took out of it.
No more doing good things now.
No!
This is what happens when I try to be a nice person.
Greed is the best?
Okay, to be fair.
They had, like...
I was a little greedy, though.
Because, like, I saw that they were like, oh, we have some water for you guys.
And coffee.
But it was, like, from a coffee machine.
So there's, like, those, like, pot...
Like, the coffee...
Like, the coffee, like, pots that they use.
Was, like, you know, they're, like, McDonald's.
The McDonald's ice mocha shit or whatever.
And then, like...
And then, I was like, oh, I don't want to drink, like, free...
Like, what's it called?
Like, those, like, coffee maker stuff.
And then, I was just like...
Yeah, the pots.
I was like, oh, I don't really want to drink pots.
And then, they have, like, water.
And then, I see, like, in the fridge, there was, like, boba tea.
I was like...
I was just like, boba...
I was like, wait, I want that.
You know, they didn't offer it.
But I saw in the fridge, they put their, like, boba orders there.
I was like, wait a minute.
I want boba.
So, I was like...
I was just like...
Can I have...
Can we...
Can I get some fresh boba?
And they're like, oh, yeah, there's a boba tea store nearby.
There's...
Yeah, we can order them for you.
And I'm like...
For free.
So, I managed to get Min and I free boba tea while we were practicing.
Anyway, so I was like...
Thank God.
So, we got that.
And it was so tiring.
By the way, seeing Mint dance IRL is fucking crazy.
Like, she's such a good dancer.
Obviously, I can't spoil the set list.
But she's like...
She's a really good dancer.
And then there's me.
And I was like...
We're doing the duo dance.
I was like...
I was just like, bro...
I feel...
I was like, oh my God, you can tell who's the dancer when we were dancing.
Yeah.
Yeah, she's so good.
Oh my God, it's crazy.
And then there was me.
And I'm like...
Like, I had to do like...
Like, during my solos...
I had to...
Like, practicing for my solos...
I had to do like...
I had to do so many practices.
But like, for Mint, she was like...
She's like...
Like, one or two times.
And then she's like, I'm good with practice.
And I'm like, what do you mean you're good?
Like, for her solos.
Like, I was like...
What do you mean you're okay?
I was like...
And then I was like, I need more.
Can I get like...
Can I do it like five to six more times?
And they're like, yeah, you can.
You can practice it five, six more times.
And I'm like...
And she's like...
I'm done.
And like, my moves are already...
What are you doing?
She was like...
She was like fucking jumping and bouncing.
And I was just like...
My dance lessons did not prepare me for this.
I was like trying to remember my moves and everything.
And then like...
Like, oh my god.
Anyway.
Anyway, yeah.
So that was...
That was like what dance practice was like.
Oh!
Oh, the...
It was so...
Okay, the organizers.
It was so sweet.
Wait, let me show you guys.
They actually gave me something.
When I got there.
It's so...
It's so stupid.
I was happy, but also I was like...
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
So...
Okay, I need to make sure it's not...
Okay, I need to...
Okay, so...
I'm gonna...
Let me double check the picture real fast.
For any...
Alright, there we go.
Okay, so...
So...
This is what the organizers gave me.
They gave me a custom made Funko Pop.
Because they were like...
We heard that you've always wanted a Funko Pop.
So we got you a custom made Funko Pop.
And then...
And then they got me...
They got me a custom Oreo.
Mint got this one too.
The Oreo thing.
She has one with the wisp.
I have one of Croquis.
I didn't try it.
I didn't want to eat it.
Because it's so cute.
But they gave me these.
And it was so sweet of them.
The organizers.
They gave Mint and I both the Oreos.
And then they gave me the Funko Pop.
Because they were like...
We know you've always wanted a Funko Pop of yourself.
That's your dream collab.
And I was like...
It is.
That literally is my dream collab.
It's so funny.
I love it so much.
But yeah.
Speaking of Funko Pop.
I saw my Nendoroid two days ago.
The colored version of the Nendoroid.
And all I can say is that...
You might be able to pre-order it...
Very, very soon.
Very, very, very soon.
That's all I'll say.
How soon?
Before the year is over.
So yeah.
Make sure you have the funds for pre-ordering.
But I'm so excited.
I'm so, so excited.
I showed Mint it.
Because I was sent...
I was like...
When I was in the car.
Heading to the studio.
She like...
I was sent the pictures.
And then I showed Mint the...
I showed it to Mint.
And she thought it was really cute.
So I'm super happy that it looked really, really good.
Yeah, but yeah.
I'm super excited.
I'm really excited.
I really hope that this provides more opportunities in the future.
For the concert.
So we can have streaming tickets next time.
Because I know like...
I know.
I'm sorry we couldn't get streaming tickets this year.
But maybe in the future.
If we do this again.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
But...
We both are going to be uploading videos and stuff.
So...
Recordings and photos are allowed.
For the concert.
And like...
Mint and I are both going to upload our favorite performances on our channel.
So like...
For those who can't make it.
We'll still have like parts of the concert.
You guys can watch.
So I'm super excited.
I'm super excited.
Let me check my little thing that I wrote.
About like...
Stuff I want to talk to you guys about.
Let me...
Oh yeah.
Dad's not here.
He's still at the sitter.
Doki Amber Doge is still not here.
Because he's still at the sitter.
Because like...
I was...
I came back.
You know.
I felt really sick.
So I was supposed to pick him up today.
But I felt really sick.
So...
Not like really...
Like I didn't feel okay.
So...
So I was just like...
Okay.
Can you...
Can you like...
Oh wait.
That's the photo.
Let me...
I need to fix the transform.
So like...
I was like...
Can you take care of him for one more day?
And she was like...
Yeah.
I can.
But like...
They sent me daily photos.
And I saw this.
And I was like...
He's not going to want to come back.
Man.
He's...
So
I was like...
I don't think he wants to come back.
He's like...
100% okay.
He's living the dream life.
It's dead.
He's just like...
He doesn't want to come back.
I don't think he wants to come back.
Guys.
He looks...
He looks way to comfy.
Like this is the original...
Like what?
We've lost him.
I saw this.
I was like...
Oh man.
Okay.
It's like, tomorrow I'll have to go back.
Oh my god, the cozy is so comfy.
So yeah, like, I saw that and I was like, I don't even know if he wants to come back, man.
I don't even know if he wants to come back.
He wants to!
Oh yeah, that's like, that's a dad update.
That's a dad update for today.
Let's see.
Oh yeah!
By the way, I forgot how restrictive the TSA is for Americans when you go to America.
Cause like, when I... Okay, so like, I was so annoyed.
Because, um, I was really annoyed.
Because like, I haven't flown to America in a long, long, long time.
Like, but I flew to like, everywhere else in the world, by the way.
I've gone to so many other places in the world.
But in America, like, I forgot how restrictive it is.
Why did I say that?
Well, it's because like, I'm not used...
I'm not used to like, taking...
Okay, so like, basically I would put my laptop in my checked baggage.
Because I was like, I don't need to use my laptop on the plane.
So I put it in my checked in baggage.
And... And like, any other place in the world, it has worked.
Putting my laptop in a checked baggage.
Cause like, I'm like, I don't need to put... I don't want to put it in my...
Cause like, I'm not going to be using it.
So like, that's my mindset.
That's my mindset.
I've never... And then...
I was like, uh...
I was like, I was like, oh, um...
Yeah, like, they're like, no, you have to...
You have to take it out.
And I was like, cause they're like, are there any laptops in there?
And I was like, yeah, I've been checking it in.
And they're like, you have to take it out.
And I was like, what?
I'm so confused.
I'm so... I'm so confused.
Cause like, I didn't know that.
I didn't know that.
Cause like, I've never had...
Like, we were like, the battery's going to explode.
It didn't pass.
But, I've done that for like...
Since I've... Since I've got a laptop.
I've always put it in my checked baggage.
I've done...
So, I was so confused.
So...
So, yeah, they're like...
Cause I was like, okay.
And I had to like, you know, I had to do the shame.
You know, the opening up your luggage shame in front of the desk.
So, I had to do that.
I was just like...
Like, opening up my luggage in front of everybody.
So, I could get my laptop out.
And I was like...
No, it's not true.
I put my checked...
I put my laptop in checked baggages in international...
Like, everywhere else in the world but America.
I've done... I've done that since I've had a laptop.
Cause I never had to use a laptop on the plane.
And so...
So, like, I did that.
And then...
I forgot that you guys have to take off your shoes.
And...
And like, you have to put everything.
Cause sometimes you don't.
Sometimes, like, taking off your shoes is like a choice.
Like...
It's like a choice.
So, like, I forgot you have to put everything.
Yeah.
Like...
So, like, to America, you have to.
But, like, something...
In international flights, it's like a choice.
It's not like a...
It's not like a thing you have to do.
The funniest thing about it is that...
The TSA in Canada...
Like, in Canada...
The...
The, like, baggage stuff...
Like, to check it, it's like separate.
I think the TSA is responsible for...
The flights to America side.
Cause, like, you know, when I fly international flights...
Or, like...
It's different from...
It's different from on the...
Cause it's separated between, like, American flights and international flights.
So...
Like, it's international as in America is not international flight.
But, it's like...
The America side in the Canadian airport...
It's it's own thing.
Which I thought was, like, crazy.
Because...
Not crazy, but, like, it's actually pretty weird for me.
Cause I was like...
It's like...
If you're going to anywhere but America...
You get to go to this side.
But, if you go to America, you have to go to this specific TSA check.
So, and it's like more strict, but it's in the same airport.
Like...
It's like in the same airport, but it's much more stricter than the everywhere else.
And...
And then, like...
I got called over...
Like, before I could get to, like, the scanning part...
Like, I...
Before I got over...
To...
The scanning part of my luggage.
Like, my carry-on.
They pulled me aside...
To, like...
Because my bag was particularly...
My carry-on bag was particularly big.
So, they did a separate inspection...
Of my lap...
And then, they're like, what's in your bag?
And I was like, my laptop.
Mostly, it's my laptop.
And they're like...
They, like, just took my laptop and, like, you know...
Tested it if it's a bomb or something.
Like, you know, the...
Like, they did the wipe thing.
And...
So, they did that.
This is me, like, still in Canada, by the way.
I'm still in Canada.
Like, I haven't crossed the border yet.
I haven't...
I haven't crossed the border yet.
Like, they want...
They test you before you go through the border.
Because then it would be Canada's problem.
But, like, it's like Americans and Canadian border.
But they test you before you go, Pat.
So, it's like...
Anyway, then after I...
You know, they did...
They're like, it's not a bomb.
So, then I went to the x-ray thing.
And then, my bag got, like, marked again.
Because it's a laptop.
So, they retested my laptop.
And I was like...
You already tested my laptop?
Why do you have to do it again?
What's the first lady fucking wrong?
Like...
I'm just like...
What's the first lady fucking wrong?
Like, why do you have to do it again?
So...
Like, when they were, you know, fucking testing my laptop again...
Um...
They were...
I was like, oh yeah, like...
Because it's taking a while.
So, I was like, oh yeah.
Because they were, like, fucking inspecting my laptop and everything.
Like, flipping it and stuff.
And then I was like...
Oh, um...
Like, the lady pulled me aside and already looked over the laptop.
And then she was like, yeah, but that's random.
That's a random search.
I'm like, but you still have the same thing.
You're doing the same thing.
What do you mean?
I won the gacha twice.
That shouldn't matter.
Like, it's already okay.
It's already okay.
You already tested it.
Um...
But yeah, that was, um...
That was, like, basically my adventures with the TSA in Canada.
In Canada.
Um...
Thank you, thank you.
But, like...
I've never had to do that before.
Like, in my...
They didn't care.
They didn't...
They're like...
The thing is...
The agent was like...
When I checked in my bag...
They were like...
Um...
If we find out you have a laptop in there...
We will break open your luggage.
And I was like, whoa.
I was like, I'm pretty sure my luggage was never broken into before.
But okay.
But I don't want to play with America.
Like...
That's why...
I was like, whoa.
Okay.
Yeah, that's what they told me.
I was like...
So first class doesn't get...
Maybe it's because I was in business class.
So they're like...
They treated me better.
Wait, I think that's it.
I was never told.
Because I would always check in as business class.
And like...
If you guys don't know...
People in business class get priority.
So they get priority...
Checks and everything.
So...
They don't have to line up.
They get their own separate queue and stuff.
So...
But yeah.
Anyway, so...
When I did a return flight...
When I did the return flight back to Canada...
I wanted to upgrade to first class.
Because they didn't have business class.
And like...
I was like...
In my head, I was like...
Well, if I want to pay for an upgrade...
I might as well pay for first class instead of economy plus.
And then...
On the website, it said there were seats left.
But I couldn't book any.
And...
Um...
So I was like...
To the check in, I was like...
No, it's because I had a hell...
My time was hell flying over in economy.
So I didn't want to do that again.
Because that was the day I realized that...
In economy, your seats are not slanted.
It's so fucked up.
Like...
In economy plus, the seats are at least slanted.
But in economy, it's not.
I don't understand.
It's just straight up.
I was like...
That's so fucked up.
It's to fit more people.
At least, I just want the bare minimum.
I just want a little bit of slack.
I...
Anyway...
Um...
Anyway, so...
Uh...
I was like...
So I...
I want to upgrade to first class.
Because I might as well.
So I was like...
I don't understand.
On the website, it says that...
It says that...
There's seats left, but I can't upgrade it.
And they're like...
Oh yeah, like...
We always reserve seats for our gold members first.
I'm like...
What?
So like...
Our gold members, when they check in, we're gonna give them the free upgrade.
I'm like...
Like...
I will pay.
I was just like...
What?
The guy was like...
I know, it's very reverse.
I was just like...
I'm like...
But...
I would pay right now.
I'm just like...
But they booked economy.
They booked economy.
I'm like...
What do you mean?
They can't be...
They're getting a free upgrade.
They booked economy.
I'm just like...
It's not like they're gonna suddenly buy first class all of a sudden.
If they booked economy now, they're always gonna book economy.
I was just like...
You have seats.
I didn't understand.
You have...
You have seats.
I was gonna give you free money.
I was gonna give you money for first class.
Anyway, so...
So then I just upgraded to economy plus.
Yeah, if they're a gold member, they should be able to pay for first class.
But they spent it on economy.
I was willing to give money.
And then they're like...
Oh, yeah.
So anyway, we're just gonna wait for these guys to see if they take the offer.
But they usually do.
Of course they usually do!
It's free!
It's a free upgrade!
You can come back later when we're about to board if the first class seats are still available.
And I'm just like...
As if they're gonna fucking say no to first class.
It's a free upgrade.
I'm just like...
Of course they're gonna say yes!
It's literally a free upgrade!
They're gonna fucking say no!
But I did try.
I was desperate.
I did try.
Literally like 10 minutes before boarding, I went up to the desk.
And it was the same guy, by the way.
The guy who did my check-in.
He was still there.
He was there to board my plane.
To do the boarding of the plane.
And I was like...
Hi, I just want to know if there's...
I didn't recognize him.
Because I already deleted him from my head.
Because I was like...
Useless!
Gone!
Don't remember what you look like!
Anyway, so I was like...
First class upgrade.
And it was the same guy.
You know how I realized it was the same guy?
He was like...
They took the free upgrades.
And I'm like...
They're like...
Sorry, ma'am.
They took the free upgrades.
And I'm like...
So I couldn't...
I flew back in Economy Plus.
And that was the flight...
Where I was the middle seat of Economy Plus.
And I had to sit next to this lady.
Who was new to flying.
Because she kept taking pictures of the sky.
I got more leg room.
But that fucking lady was...
Kept taking pictures of the sky.
In the open window.
And I was the middle seat.
I was the middle seat.
But at least I had more leg room.
At least.
Thank you for the super chat.
Leave that lady alone.
About the TSA.
Fun fact.
During last year's AX.
I had all my locks snipped.
Because TSA...
Holy fuck.
They can do this to us with no refund.
For...
Jesus Christ.
That's...
That's fucking crazy.
That's actually...
TSA has...
Too much power.
Oh my god.
That's insane.
Just because they felt like it.
Dude, that's crazy.
Yeah, so...
That was my flight.
That's the day I learned.
I don't think I'll ever do economy again.
Because I don't want to be treated like that again.
Sorry.
Now that I know...
What it's like more recently.
I don't want to go through...
I don't want to go through that again.
I don't think I can go back.
That's why I work...
It's time to work even harder.
It's time.
So I don't have to do that again.
Also...
You know what grinds my gears?
Anyway.
You know what grinds my gears, guys?
Iced tea is not iced tea in America.
Iced tea is like...
They're literal.
Okay, so...
I was so confused.
Because like...
I ordered iced tea.
But the thing is, iced tea in the rest of the world...
It's like...
Lemon tea.
That's what we mean...
By iced tea.
If you order iced tea anywhere else...
It's like lemon tea.
But then when I order iced tea in America...
It's literally tea.
It's tea, but iced.
Yeah, it's...
It's...
It's so weird.
It's actually tea.
I keep thinking...
It's gonna be like...
It comes with a lemon, but...
And then I got four.
Because I was like...
That's the iced tea I knew, because it came with a lemon.
And then...
But then...
But...
But it didn't taste like lemon.
It's like...
It's actually tea.
I was so confused.
I was like...
What is this?
It is...
It's literally iced tea.
That threw me off.
I was just thinking...
I can't wait to get me some sweet tea.
Some sweet lemon tea.
And then it's just iced.
It's just tea with some ice in it.
I got so confused.
I drank it and I was like...
It's not even sweet.
I was like...
What the fuck is this bullshit?
If I wanted to be healthy, I would just drink water.
If I wanted to be healthy, why the fuck would I order iced tea?
I would just drink regular water.
Like regular iced water.
I'm fucking saying sweet tea.
I was looking at the menu and they were like...
Oh, we have iced tea in the menu.
And I was like...
Yay, iced tea.
Anyway, so...
That like...
That tilted me so hard.
Not hard, but that tilted me a little bit.
Because I was like...
I just wanted...
I wanted my iced tea.
But it's actually iced tea.
It's just tea, but cold.
Like what is this fucking bullshit?
The world is very confusing.
Also like...
Guys...
What is unusual?
Okay, I was like...
Talking to my friends about this today.
Because like...
I need to print out postcards for...
By the way, I've been signing postcards non-stop.
Now I'm signing my own postcards.
Like yesterday and today.
But the thing is...
I need to print new postcards for my other stuff.
So, I'm like thinking...
What is this?
I just found out about this.
Because I was like...
4x6 is American...
Did you guys know 4x6 is like American sizes?
It's like US size.
The rest of the world does not use our paper sizes.
And I just found out.
I just found out.
I just found out about this.
Because I was like...
Because you know, they don't use inches.
And we do.
Because I was like being like...
Oh yeah, what do like companies...
Like Corpo VTubers do?
Size print for postcards.
And then...
My friend who does like...
Artist Alley stuff.
She was like...
Oh yeah, it's 4.1x5.8.
I was like...
That's such a weird size.
It's just like...
Why the fuck is it 4.1x5.8?
I was like...
That's weird.
And then she was like...
No, we're weird.
We're literally the only...
And it's the only...
Only content that uses...
It's own sizes.
Like...
We're the only ones that use...
Inches.
We're the weird ones.
And I was like...
I was like...
Wait, what?
They use ABC.
And I'm like...
What the fuck is ABC?
I was like...
And they're like...
That's what the rest of the world uses.
We use US paper sizes.
Cause we're like...
Letter, legal, and tabloid.
But you guys have A3, A4, A5.
And I'm like...
I'm like...
The fuck is...
The fuck is 4.1x5.8?
That's such a weird thing.
That's such a weird dimension.
Like...
Okay, so...
Yeah, so...
I found that out today.
Cause I was like...
4x16 is really small.
Cause I have my postcards.
I'm signing the current postcards right now.
And it's really small.
I thought it was really small.
Cause I was like...
4x16 is not that big.
It seems really thin.
And then...
I was asking my friends.
I was like...
Do you guys own any...
Company?
Vtuber merch?
What sizes are they normally?
Cause the ones I have...
I don't even remember if I packed them.
I don't know where it is.
So I couldn't check.
Physically.
So I was like...
Oh man, what are the sizes?
Cause I felt like it was a little bigger.
Cause I was looking at photos.
I was looking at Hololive birthday postcard merch.
Cause it doesn't say the dimensions.
And I was looking at my postcard.
And I was trying to compare it.
I was putting it up on the screen.
And comparing it.
And I was like...
Yours look bigger.
I was like...
Yours look a little bigger.
I was comparing it.
I was like...
Wait, it looks wider.
Cause it is wider!
Cause my friend was like...
Yeah, we use 4x6.
They use 4.1.
There might be like...
5.8 and we're 6.
But theirs is wider.
So I was like...
They're 1 inch wider.
Don't fucking wonder.
I was like...
Oh my god!
My 4x6 is 4.1!
Cause I was like...
Wondering...
Why does mine look smaller?
Like less wide.
0.1 makes a huge difference, guys.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Hi Doki.
You and Mint are my kami-oshis.
So Phantom Thief concert made me confused.
I wanted a happy birthday from you and Mint.
But forgot my birthday was not the 18th of...
Next month.
By the way, you forgot your own birthday.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I'll sing you a happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the superchat, Cypher.
Thank you, thank you.
4.1 is the...
No, it's not!
It can be landscape.
It can be interchangeable, guys.
It can be landscape or portrait.
It doesn't matter.
You can rotate it.
That's what you can do.
So like...
Is it like...
FYI, Canada Post is going on strike.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, guys.
My distributor messaged me and was telling me Canada Post is now on strike, guys.
I'm so sorry.
Wait, it's my life!
I didn't know!
Okay.
I've been getting emails about Canada Post but I wasn't reading it.
Oh, I should have read.
They're like negotiation updates from Canada Post.
Okay, there we go.
Alright, so anyway.
Canada Post is now on strike.
Again.
I was gonna mail out some of the signed postcards like this week.
So...
That's so unfortunate.
You get used to it.
Oh my god.
I would need it to fucking...
Oh my god, I guess it's pick up time.
Anyway.
For those who don't know, Canada Post, for US packages, you're fine, apparently.
But the Canadians and international orders will be affected.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Canada.
Please!
Oh my god, they're smart though.
They chose the holiday season.
They're so smart.
If you wanna get stuff received before the holidays, this is the time you start shipping stuff.
So they're really smart in choosing this month to strike because people are not getting shit for Christmas.
That's for sure.
They have to agree or Christmas is cancelled.
Simple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who's on our nickel while you're here in the US?
Wait, who?
Who's looking at coins?
I've been fucking beeping things with my credit card.
I never received any coins.
Oh my god.
I'm so uber brained that I've been taking ubers for so long that I almost just walked out on a taxi because I was like and then the guy when I got to the airport when I came back home yesterday I literally just walked out in a taxi because I thought I was on an uber.
The taxi guy was like, excuse me ma'am.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
I thought I was in an uber.
I got the uber brain right.
I legitimately was like, it's already paid for.
I was so tired too.
I was so tired.
I legitimately thought I was in an uber.
Okay, but yeah.
That was basically it.
Let's see.
Oh yeah.
Wait, never mind.
I forgot what I wanted to say.
Oh yeah, nothing by the way.
Oh yeah, nothing.
I guess I didn't talk much about seeing mint.
I feel like we talked about a lot already.
But during the off collab stream that was like on her channel in the twitter space.
By the way, we had a twitter space.
I know some posted an archive of the twitter space because she forgot to fucking record it.
There wasn't really a lot of stories.
We didn't get to do a lot of stuff.
We were just working.
I just hanged out in her room after dance practices and after work and we would just work even more.
That's really it.
We would just work and gossip.
We didn't do much.
We were just working and gossiping in her room.
We couldn't do anything outside of that.
Legitimately, it's like food.
The only times outside of work was just getting free food.
Free dinner and free lunch.
We were doing girl talk.
Just talking about random stuff in general.
It's just that.
Just hearing you chat and hang out was awesome.
Thank you for the super chat, Nexy.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad.
When we saw each other, we hugged.
She hugged me.
I don't hug a lot.
She saw me when we were at the hotel lobby and she hugged me.
I hugged back.
It was really fun to hang out with her.
We did a lot of stuff together at the practice.
Just hanging out in her room and stuff.
That's basically it.
We were like, bye!
When we left, it was just like, see you next month!
Bye!
That's really it.
I just felt like there was not a lot to really talk about.
We already talked a lot during the off collab stream and during the twitter space.
We already talked about what was going on and everything.
I had nothing new to add.
We were there for three days.
There was nothing much to add on to it.
I said, me and I were just working.
I had plans.
I told some of my friends who live near the place that I'll be there.
I had zero time to meet up with anybody.
No time.
We literally spent all our days in the hotel at the studio or eating.
We had no free time at all.
Only when I left, my friends were messaging me being like, what's your schedule?
I was like, I'm on the plane back home.
I was like, I'm sorry.
I should've told you guys earlier.
I literally had zero time.
I had no time at all.
I couldn't even message my friends being like, I don't have my schedule.
It's not free.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
All I did was work.
I'm so sorry.
Next time.
I'm already on the plane back.
I'm so sorry.
Blade, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
They might give you some brain rot memes or vice versa.
Blade, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
We're just quoting the wave.
We were doing the head at the studio.
We were like, in our 3D models.
We were like, wave.
And sticking our head out in our 3D model and stuff.
We were doing the club penguin dances.
And like, soldier boy and stuff in 3D.
Coyote, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your Aqualad dynamic was so wonderful and funny.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We were being really silly.
We were literally quoting that the last three days.
We kept quoting it.
We're Costco guys.
We actually got brain rotted so hard.
But yeah, that was basically what we were doing the last three days.
But yeah, honestly, I missed you guys though.
I really missed streaming.
Like I said, I couldn't really stream when I was there.
We were working so much.
We were so tired.
Every time I went back to my room, I just passed out.
I just went to bed and then like, back to work the next day.
I literally just passed out after hanging out in Min's room.
I passed out and went to bed and sleep.
Then wake up, it's work hours.
It's work hours again.
So I'm glad to be back and streaming for you guys again.
Anyway, I'm gonna call it here.
Chat, I'm gonna call it here.
I'm gonna run out of things to say.
But it's really nice to be back here again.
It's really nice to be back in Canada and hanging out and talking with my dragons again.
I hope you guys missed me, because I missed you guys.
Oh wait, before I go.
So what's the postcard standard for VTuber merch?
Guys, like...
Guys!
Guys, for any of you guys that have the...
Guys, I need for research purposes, guys.
What sizes are they?
Like, I don't know what the international size is.
Like, I think like...
My friend says A6 or whatever.
Like 4.1x5.
Guys, I know you guys have VTuber postcards.
I know you guys have it.
Okay, it's A6.
Okay, nice.
Anyway.
I forgot to talk about this part of the story.
So I was asking...
I was asking like...
So I was asking my friend.
I was like, how do I get A6 size?
And then she was like, you don't.
I was like, how do I...
How do I do that in NA?
And she's just like, you don't.
We don't have the machines for that.
Unless you want to pay more to have it printed outside of NA.
And I'm like, oh.
That's a neat part.
So we're using 4x...
So I guess it's gonna be 4x6.
We have to make do with that.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna head out now.
As always, everybody...
By the way, have you seen FemMedi and FemCaz, the Dragoons?
Next thing, thank you for the super chat.
And I will crush it down and make sure it doesn't blow up.
Unlike Mint, I know how to stop things.
Thank you.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated, pause to check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you, except for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.